and what also was scary is the
unwillingness to look at the the result
of your actions even if your actions
were uh the intent was was a with a
valid intent or a a kind intent uh the
800 pound elephant in the room in this
country is the large number of kids who
enter the world without a father married
to the mother in 1965 25 of black kids
entered the world without a father
married to the mother and forget about
elder barack obama once said
a kid raised without a dad is five times
more likely to commit
to be poor and and commit crime nine
times more likely to drop out of school
and 20 times more likely to end up in
prison now it's 70 percent of black kids
entering the world without a father
married to the mother it's because the
welfare state has incentivized women to
marry the government and incentivize men
to abandon their financial and more
responsibility 40 of all kids in america
born without a father in the house 25 of
white kids half of all hispanic kids and
we are doing nothing about it we're not
even talking about even republicans
don't talk about it and when you don't
have a father in the house it's not just
an act a um a financial problem which is
which is huge it's you don't see two
adults interact civilly resolve problems
you don't see somebody get up and go to
work in the morning when he doesn't want
feel like going all the values that it
takes in order to be a responsible
citizen you don't have that's why we
have so much crime and such dropouts
right now and a lot of people who are
functionally illiterate eighth
eighty-five percent of eighth grade
black kids in america can either read
nor write at proficiency levels that
means eighty-five percent of eighth
graders black eighth graders are
functionally illiterate when you are
functionally illiterate you are easily
misled by emotion and it's a huge
problem and both both parties in my
opinion completely ignore that issue
yeah i think well i think it aids
certain political parties because the
kids end up looking to the government
they look for a strong one they look for
a father and a boogeyman and they and
they look for something that made them a
victim and that's why so many black
people are misled into believing that
america systemically racist it is not i
was i was talking to uh i was talking to
some local school professionals
and one of the things that i was talking
about with some people there was
people don't know what to do with their
lives people want to work hard but let's
say this let's say right now you
lost your job and you're like you know
what i really love doing i really love
making birdhouses
how do i start a company that makes
birdhouses i don't know step one the
funny thing is we look at video games
like world of warcraft so popular it's
gamified this this dopamine release
where you accomplish goals but it's fake
the difference i was talking about why
is it that people will sit there playing
a video game where they get the the
forest leather boots of agility but they
won't just go and actually level
themselves up right the thing is no
forest boots that's why no it's because
in the real world there is no quest
giver who says if you do 10 push-ups you
will then see plus one strength
they there's there's there's no
leadership and it's in line with what
you're saying about fathers when you
have someone who says here is your quest
and they accomplish their quest they get
a dopamine hit it feels good in a video
game they tell you what to do you do it
it works you've accomplished your goal
yeah this is what we were missing from
in real life we're starting to lose in
real life as you were mentioning with
with that and the irony the the
information to build a birdhouse and to
start a business has never been more
accessible or you can do is go online
never has information been more easily
obtained and cheaply obtained than it is
right now but you don't have somebody to
give you guidance you don't have
somebody to tell you you need to defer
gratification
work hard there's a connection between
that and and having a good result and
this is why i think the the one of the
reasons the democrats are so hell-bent
on stopping school choice
because you keep people ignorant what
happens they graduate from college doing
the wrong things and then think
i don't understand what i'm supposed to
do if what i did didn't work the system
must not work
meanwhile people with proper guidance
succeed they find that success and they
say
you can make it you can make it happen
so what i want to see happen is people
get good guidance and leadership so they
know those first steps absolutely but
that's not what we're getting from the
school system that's not what we're
getting from welfare programs what we're
getting from david goggins right people
like goggins and rogan and you tim
people like everything i followed your
work later you know but uh you people
like larry elder like every time i
struggle every time i'm depressed i
don't go to a therapist i'm like typing
david doggett
i literally looked up jocko breakup
advice after my last breakup um jordan
peterson
as i said i've been on radio for 30
years and in 30 years i have not been
able to get jesse jackson on my radio
show maxine waters uh al sharpton uh uh
louis farrakhan even though i've reached
out to them hundreds of times
the one so-called black leader terminal
pickling like who came on my show was a
guy named kawasa imfume he's a
congressman from maryland
at the time he was a president of the
naacp he was a congressman both before
and after becoming president of the
naacp and my first question was mr
imphume as between the presence of white
racism or the absence of black fathers
which poses the bigger problems of the
black community without missing a beat
ian he said the absence of black fathers
again far and away the biggest problem
and barack obama's first book was all
about
the angst over not having a dad in his
house a dream from my father al sharpton
had a nice middle class life until his
father ran away with another woman into
the hood he went uh louis farrakhan's
mother was estranged from
her husband had a boyfriend took back up
with louis farrakhan
and she tried to abort him with a coat
hanger jesse jackson's mother was a
teenage mom who lived next next door to
a married man who impregnated her and
jackson grew up in south carolina when
growing up without a dad was rare and he
was teased jesse ain't got no daddy just
ain't got no daddy the reason i'm
mentioning this is these are arguably
the four most prominent so-called black
leaders all of whom either have no
relationship with their dads or a poor
relationship with one and they never
talk about it obama every now and then
says something but by and large they
never talk about it they talk about
racism racism racism when it's never
been less significant in america you
mentioned early in the show your dad
and that you had you know a 10-year
period maybe a falling out right but
prior to that how was it for you growing
up with your dad well my father uh was
was uh grouchy and angry and he spanked
us a lot my two brothers with with belts
and i thought it was excessive and i
intently disliked the man and
fortunately when i'm a little kid he 10
years old he starts a little cafe and i
have to work for the sob and he still
yells it now i'm 15 years old tim and i
said to myself next time he yells it man
we're talking about a diner where
everybody can hear everything it's not
like it's privately in the back he yells
and screams at me and you're looking at
customers watching the whole thing i
said i'm going to walk out next time
this sob yells at me and it took me
three or four times to work up the
courage to do it but i did when i was 15
years old
my dad came home he paid me 10 dollars a
day plus tips he bought the ten dollars
and lay on the bed he threw it at me and
he said why did you leave and for the
first time i spoke back to my dad and i
said dad i got sick and tired of the way
you spoke to me and i'm not putting up
with it anymore he walked out of my
bedroom tim and for the next 10 years we
didn't speak to each other at all wow at
all i go to college i go to law school i
come home to visit my mom of course
college was in new england law school's
in the midwest i'd come back to l.a to
visit my mom but i'd make sure my dad
wasn't around when i when i was in the
room you were 15
i was 15 when this happened
uh but then i graduated from high school
my dad worked long hours for the next
two years i just made sure we weren't in
the same room then then i go to new
england for for college midwest for law
school end up working in cleveland and i
would visit my mom all these years of
course but i would just make sure my dad
and i were not in the same room we said
nothing each other for 10 years now just
just real quickly um
now i'm 25 years old i passed the
california bar the ohio bar i should be
living large i'm 25 years old making the
equivalent of 150k
and i can't sleep and i know it has to
do with my dad so i told my secretary
call my uh call my client tell him i'm
going to be away for three days i'm
flying to la i'll be back and so i
didn't tell my parents i was coming
because i didn't want my dad to prepare
so i go to get to lax took a cab to the
cafe cafe closed at 2 30 i got there at
1 30
and my dad was shocked to see me i had
two big bags with me and he said i put
your bags in the back i said no dad i
would be here for five or ten minutes i
want to tell you something
so he said wait till we close so i sat
there for an hour and i said
all right don't tee off on the sob just
give him the highlights five ten minute
conversation he'll call you an
ungrateful grateful son you'll call him
a cruel father and maybe you'll be able
to sleep when you get back to cleveland
so my dad sat down and i teed off for
him for a half hour you know how i can
go we just now met but you know how
so i spoke for a half hour nonstop every
spanking every whipping the time when my
cousin elaine came to cleveland from
cleveland to visit me and he with me in
front of her how humiliating that word i
told him everything and my dad just took
it every now and then he'd lean over and
pour coffee and replenish his coffee but
he just took it
and when i was done i was spent i
couldn't think of anything else and my
dad looked up and said is that it
you just be you didn't speak to me for
10 years because of that now i should
tell you i knew nothing about my
father's life other than i knew he was
an only child because we never got any
christmas presents and i met his mom one
time outside of that i knew nothing
about his life i didn't care i didn't
like him
he said let me tell you about
my father
you know your last name elder i said yes
he said that's not my father's last name
i said what
what's your father's last name he said i
have no idea i never met him you never
met your father who's elder elder was
some guy who was in my life the longest
four years my mother couldn't either
read nor write she had a series of
boyfriends each one more irresponsible
than the one before elder was an
alcoholic was physically abusive to me
and when i tried to stop him from
beating my mother he would beat me
and i came home at 13 years old he said
and i started fighting with my mom's
then boyfriend by that time elder was
long gone
and my mother sided with the boyfriend
and threw me out of the house 13 years
old never to return athens georgia jim
crow south at the beginning of the great
depression i said well dad
what did you do and for the next eight
hours the man told me about his life two
stools as close as you and i are
and
for the first time i found my i saw my
father cry when he talked about the way
elder treated him
for eight hours my dad walked me through
his life i said what did you do when you
left the house i went down the road i
picked up trash i did this
i became a pullman porter they were the
private largest private employers of
blacks in those days my dad came out to
california on a run and he was able to
walk through the front door of a
restaurant and get served and he was
shocked and he said maybe i'll make a
middle note to relocate to california
pearl harbor my dad joins the marines i
said dad why the marines anybody who's
listening to us who's in the marines
knows what i'm going to say two reasons
number one the goal where the action is
number two i love the uniforms my dad
was stationed on guam
where he became a staff sergeant in
charge of cooking for the colored
colored soldiers gets out come back to
chattanooga where you're appearing thank
you um and once i worked that in
where he met where he met married my mom
to get him a job as a short order cook
that's what he did in the military and
they said i'm sorry we don't hire in
there he went to restaurant after
restaurant i'm sorry we don't hire again
go to the unemployment office
go through the door lady says you went
through the wrong door i said colored
only my dad goes through that door to
the very same lady who sent him out my
dad told my mom this is bs i'm going to
la where i was before the war i'm gonna
get a job as a cook i'll send for you
comes out to l.a walks around for a day
and a half and he said sorry you don't
have any references
my dad said i need references to make
ham and eggs
and uh but they treated him the same way
as they did in chattanooga a little more
polite yeah close to unemployment office
just one door this time lady didn't have
anything my dad said what time do you
close she says diane what time do you uh
what time do you open she said what time
do you close five my dad said i'll be
sitting in that chair until you find me
something sat there for a whole day
nothing came back the next day she calls
them up i've got something i don't know
whether or not you're going to want it
my dad's of course i'm going to want it
i'm starting a family what is it she
says a job cleaning toilet and nabisco
brand bread my dad did that for 10 years
took a second full-time job cleaning
toilets at another bread company he had
a hookup
cooked for a family on the weekend to
make additional money went to night
school three nights a week to get his
ged so he could have a stay-at-home wife
the man never slept which is why he was
so grouchy
and my dad then said you know and the
other the other time i was married
you were married before mom oh i thought
i was gonna say six months three months
seven years what happened she cheated on
me she couldn't have any kids and then
the other time i was married
you were married twice before mom
i was 18 years old i married a girl 18
her parents found out i was an 8th grade
dropout march her down to the courthouse
annulled the marriage so you were
married three times
why would you get married after that
happened to you he looked at me like i
had eight heads he said because larry i
wanted you
so eight hours my dad gets bigger and
bigger and bigger tim elder gets smaller
and smaller and smaller now i'm crying
and i said dad please forgive me for
judging you so harshly my dad said don't
worry about it just follow the advice
i've always given you and your brothers
like excited in my sleep hard work wins
you get out of life what you put into it
larry you cannot control the outcome but
you are 100 in control of the effort and
before you moan groan about what
somebody did to you or said to you go
the nearest mirror look at it and ask
yourself what could i have done to
change the outcome and finally he said
no matter how good you are how hard you
work bad things are going to happen to
you how you address those bad things
will tell your mother and me if we
raised a man from that point on next 35
years my dad and i were the best of
friends i wrote a book about this called
dear father dear son two lives eight
hours
um about the conversation the reason is
titled that
and i flew back to cleveland my dad
wrote me a letter he never wrote me a
letter in his life
and it started out dear son he never
called me dear son never call me son i
wrote back and i called him father i
never called him father and my dad and i
became the best of friends from that
point on but if anybody anybody had a
right to hate america to believe america
was systemically racist it's my dad and
he never believed that my dad was a
republican and my dad always said this
about the democratic party and then i'll
then i'll shut up
democrats want to give you something for
nothing when you try and get something
for nothing you almost always end up
getting nothing for something
larry will you be my dad
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm
we'll see you all there
you